got the chief executive of a major
company who has sacked 800 workers via
video call admitting that they knowingly
break the law and that they would do it
again as a transport secretary what is
it that you're going to do about it
well first of all i thought what the
boss of uh piano said yesterday about
knowingly breaking the law was brazen
and breathtaking showed incredible
arrogance and i cannot believe that he
can stay
in that role having uh admitted to
deliberately go out and use a loophole
uh what break the law but also use a
loophole and that's the thing what they
did was they flagged their ships through
cyprus avoided having to tell anybody
about this or they felt they did and
even though they know they've broken the
law what they've done is to
pay people off in such a way to try and
buy their silence it's unacceptable so
what i'm going to do about it is come to
parliament uh this coming week with a
package of measures which will both
close every possible loophole
that exists
and force them to u-turn on this we are
not having people working from british
ports on regular applying regular routes
between here and france or here in
holland or where else uh and and failing
to pay the minimum wage it's simply
unacceptable and we will force that to
change
so just to be clear then you said
earlier on you cannot believe that he's
still in his role so you're calling for
him to leave then you think he should go
right now
yes yes
okay that's um that's well noted there
and also let's just talk about some of
the other issues um here we all know
that this is unacceptable and you've
touched on that there you said you know
in terms of the law to make sure that
the loophole that piano exploited
isn't exploited by other people so one
of the questions that many people will
be thinking about including those 800
workers and their family members of
course who rely on them is that how can
it be that we have a company which
actually operates from ports like dover
and ken ryan how can it be that they can
avoid paying workers less than the
minimum wage because they do operate
around british ports so how is that
possible
yeah well what everyone says who looks
at this including the lawyers
is
international maritime law combined with
national laws are incredible it's an
incredibly complex area and up until now
it's been thought that that wasn't
something that they could go
and do what they've done
quite
mischievously is to register their ships
through a cypress flag
and therefore avoid and evade the uh
need to inform anybody about what they
were doing uh as the boss of uh pno
openly admitted to parliament yesterday
the most extraordinary testimonial
to the select committees uh what they
did was know that they were breaking the
law and deliberately set out to break
the law but effectively pay people off
for their silence um we can't have a
situation where uh the minimum wage
exists onshore but as soon as you're
offshore and particularly where you're
within
our economic zone that's 12 miles with
within the
off offshore of the uk and that's the
regular route you take we can't have a
situation where those people aren't
covered by british laws on things like
minimum wage and overseas uh cheap labor
is exploited on those routes um it's not
right it's not fair uh in fairness to
pno uh
fairness i can't think of anything fair
at all about what they've done but what
they have done is actually copied what
irish ferries had already done uh and of
course there's then the danger that
other operators the stena this dfds
might feel that they have to do the same
the package that i'm bringing forward
will make it absolutely clear that would
be unacceptable they won't be able to
operate from british ports if they do
and will require a u-turn on what's
happened uh at pno as well and we'll
enforce that with the law
so specifically you make them pay the
minimum wage and you change the law to
ensure that
correct that's exactly uh the plan it's
quite complex as has been revealed the
last couple of weeks because it's not a
single law it's a combination of
different laws working together okay and
differently can you simplify it for us
then can you simplify it further can you
tell us exactly when you plan on
changing this law and just tell us how
you're going to do it in a very simple
form if you can i'm going to need to i
i'm going to need to make that actual
announcement to parliament first but to
give you an idea there are measures that
we can take uh immediately with regards
to the way that ports operate
instructions to ports some ports are
what are called uh trust ports for
example uh and have a different status
and and we'd have a little bit more
control so the things that we can do
immediately
you know
and are already uh underway there are
things which require what's called
secondary legislation that's legislation
which can again be passed in relatively
quick time
and then there are things which are done
through primary legislation that
normally takes longer but i've already
spoken
to my opposite number uh in the house of
commons uh in order to try and build a
consensus around this and i'm pretty
sure um the members of parliament feel
uh the same about this i think um what's
happened is absolutely disgraceful uh
and we intend to make sure that not only
is that route blocked but actually pno
will have to a u-turn uh on all of this
as well
and when will you be making that
announcement to parliament
next week
and it's a it's a comprehensive uh
package which which contains um seven or
eight different steps that we'll be
taking eight steps actually and when are
you hoping that the new law will come
into force
well as i say there's a series of
different things which interlink and
overlap because we're dealing in part
with international maritime law as well
as for example
national minimum wage law as well as
port law and much else
it essentially
ratchets up with every different step
that we um take so my message to piano
is simple uh their their wheezes are not
going to work we are going to legally
require them to go back on it they might
as well start on that now and if they
haven't got the right leadership they
have to do it at the moment and i think
yesterday we saw through that brazen
breathtaking arrogance uh that they
don't then they will probably need to
think about sourcing that out first
mr shaps can you guarantee that those
800 workers will get to keep their jobs
what is it that you're doing to help
them i don't know that it'll be those
800 workers specifically many of them
have um
have or in the process of accepting uh
what was simply a huge payoff from uh or
a big uh payoff from pno and pno piano
admitted this is what this is an
extraordinary thing about it they said
we know we're breaking the law but don't
worry we're paying them off to not
essentially come after us for breaking
the law um i actually know that um and i
was contacted the same day uh which was
last thursday uh about um about this by
other blue chip bosses and i know
they've gone down and actually snapped
up those employees who you know
hardworking people who spent years in
many cases with piano very attractive in
a very tight labor market where
unemployment is what 3.9
those people have been snapped up so i
suspect they'll probably have to employ
others the whole thing is going to end
up costing piano
a lot more money um because of the way
they've gone about this not only will
they end up paying redundancy i suspect
they'll have to end up paying people to
come and work for them again and
actually they've got a lot of reputation
rebuilding to to do as well um so i
think everything about this the way
they've gone about has been hugely
regrettable uh we won't let the
situation stand as the prime minister
said the dispatch box on wednesday and
and next week we'll have a package of
messages measures which which makes it
absolutely clear that they they can
consider themselves on notice on this
minister just to be clear when did you
become aware of the crisis at piano when
did you first become aware of it i was
actually stood at the dispatch box on
thursday when news started to
come out
about it because i happen to have oral
questions um for completeness i should
say that the night before uh i was
informed by my office that there'll be
another round of redundancies uh at
piano uh but piano have made
redundancies in the normal way in the
past including particularly during
coronavirus and so that in itself
whilst obviously really unfortunate uh
if they'd gone through the normal
consultation process worked with the
workers worked with the unions we
wouldn't be sitting here where we are
today although as i i say actually it
would still not be acceptable for them
to be replacing people uh with uh with
people not being paid the minimum wage
so we still would have a problem if that
were the case
the chief executive yesterday said that
actually you were made aware about this
in november are you saying that he's
lying
well i've sent the note actually from
the meeting in november which was with
the parent company dp world when i was
at world
expo
where they simply said the competition's
very tough the the conditions are very
tight well we knew all that because of
coronavirus uh and and they'll be
looking at the shape of their business
and i've actually sent the formal civil
service notes of that meeting i think we
can all see that what they're trying to
do is distract attention the fact of the
matter is that they needed to give 45
days notice to ministers in fact to the
secretary of state for business uh if
you're making these kind of redundancies
they did not do that they did not
provide the uh notice they are using a
weasel approach by saying well it's
flagged to uh the cyprus flag so
therefore those are the ministers we'd
have to inform by the way they didn't
inform them with 45 days notice either
and they're simply saying we don't care
that we broke the law we did it
deliberately and we're just going to pay
people off to put their silence and none
of that is acceptable i'm afraid so
that's very clear then you're calling
for that chief exec to go and do also as
you've stated here you're going to be
changing the law to protect
those workers and also to ensure that
that loophole which piano exploited is
actually closed minister let's just talk
about some of the main issues that
you're also here to discuss you're here
to talk about the infrastructure of
electric cars and also improvements to
technologies such as the apps and charge
points can you just update us on some of
the changes that you've brought in
yeah i mean we're seeing huge numbers of
cars with plugs on the end electric cars
being sold in this country perhaps one
in four one and five right now
and so the infrastructure to charge them
needs to match it uh we do actually
already have the most rapid charges of
any western country
but we want to go a lot further there
are about 30 000 right now charges
public charges we want that to go up by
10 times to 300 000 today we're
announcing an enormous fund to help that
happen but not just increase the number
of charges also make it easier to charge
anyone who's got an electric car i've
driven one for the last three years
nearly uh knows that it's too hassly if
you turn up at a charging station and
you have to start having membership
cards and uh downloading apps we're
we're actually legislating to make all
the more fast chargers uh use
contactless payment so people just tap
their credit card or tap their their
phone and and they paid for it so a lot
more convenience a lot more uptime
because we're forcing the data to be
shared and really for the consumer for
the motorist make this a really much
less painful switch